es ist ein Alarm den CDU-Chef Friedrich
Merz da gerade sendet an die Regierung
achtung wir erleben gerade noch höhere
Flüchtlingszahlen als 2016 und das das
kann uns überfordern so märz in diesem
Jahr wahrscheinlich die höchste Zahl an
zusätzlichen Asylbewerbern haben
jenseits der Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
die über diese Balkanroute kommen und
die Zahlen sind so hoch dass wir damit
rechnen müssen dass sie insgesamt im
Jahr 2022 höher werden als im Jahr 2016
so und da erlauben wir uns auf dieses
Problem hinzuweisen und auch zu sagen
dass sie hier möglicherweise unseren
Staat einfach überfordern und das finde
ich ist eine legitime Aufgabe auch einer
politischen Partei das zu sagen
über dieses Thema möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit bayerns Innenminister
Joachim Herrmann der ja zugleich auch
Vorsitzender der Innenministerkonferenz
der Länder ist schönen guten Tag Herr
Minister
hallo grüß Gott aus München also die
migrationexperten die warnen ja schon
vor einem historischen fluchtwinter
landeskommunalpolitiker alle ziehen
schon Vergleiche mit zwei 15 zwei 16 ist
Deutschland darauf vorbereitet schaffen
wir das Herrmann
es ist das hat man gestern bei dem
Gespräch im Bundesinnenministerium
deutlich gemerkt übereinstimmen der
Auffassungen aller kommunalen
Spitzenverbände es ist die Botschaft von
den Städten und Landkreisen genauso wie
auch die Einschätzung nahezu aller
Bundesländer das ist schon jetzt am
Limit sind hinsichtlich der
Möglichkeiten Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
denn da waren zum einen natürlich die
vielen Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine die
zu uns gekommen sind und jetzt wieder
steigende Zahlen von Asylbewerbern aus
anderen Teilen der Welt das führt dazu
dass wir am Limit sind dass viele
Unterkünfte schon eher überbesetzt sind
wir nur noch sehr wenig Spielräume haben
und wenn der Zugang sich in den nächsten
zwei drei Monaten sofort setzt wie das
in den letzten zwei drei Monaten der
Fall war dann geht das auf jeden Fall
über die Möglichkeiten hinaus sie die
meisten Städte und Landkreise bislang
für sich sehen
werden wir denn dann das Versprechen
dass wir ja ausgegeben haben an die
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine durchhalten
können wir haben gesagt wir nehmen Euch
alle auf werden wir das schaffen
nun ich bin sehr froh gewesen darüber
dass die bundesinnenministerin gestern
klare erklärt hat wir müssen hier den
Zustrom von Flüchtlingen letztendlich
vor allen Dingen von illegalen Migranten
begrenzen es ist klar dass wir wirklich
nein
aber jetzt nicht um die illegalen
sondern das geht jetzt tatsächlich um
die Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine den wir
gesagt haben wir können euch alle
aufnehmen werden wir dieses Versprechen
einhalten können
das wollte ich gerade sagen die Menschen
aus der Ukraine die müssen wir aufnehmen
weil es im wahrsten Sinn des Wortes
naheliegend ist es ist aber immer im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes nicht so
naheliegend das gleichzeitig noch
Asylbewerber aus Syrien hierher kommen
die eigentlich schon drei vier Jahre in
der Türkei aufhältig waren und mit
diesen Dingen müssen wir uns jetzt
beschäftigen die Balkanroute das muss
reduziert werden aber wir wollen und wir
stehen dazu den Menschen aus der Ukraine
selbstverständlich helfen und ich spüre
nach wie vor da auch eine große
Hilfsbereitschaft in der Bevölkerung sie
haben es gerade angesprochen in
Ministerin Felser will dir jetzt die
Grenzkontrollen zu Österreich und auch
die Schleierfahndung an der Grenze zu
Tschechien intensivieren glauben Sie
dass das ausreicht um dieses Problem
jetzt wirkungsvoll zu bekämpfen dass
eben ja auch immer mehr illegale
Flüchtlinge kommen
es ist auf jeden Fall richtig und
wichtig ich habe das nachdrücklich schon
in der Vergangenheit gefordert dass die
Grenzkontrollen zu Österreich auch wenn
das für uns ja in Bayern nicht immer nur
bequem ist dass die fortgesetzt werden
dass er die bundesinnenministerinnen zu
entschieden das ist richtig die
Bundespolizei macht da einen sehr guten
Job und im übrigen neben der Frage von
illegaler Migration werden dann halt zu
täglich auch
Drogenschmuggler Waffenschmuggler andere
kriminelle aufgegriffen dass sie
sinnvoll wir haben auch mit bayerischer
Polizei neuerdings auch verstärkt durch
bayerische Bereitschaftspolizei die
schleierfahndungen entlang der
tschechischen Grenze intensiviert und
wir werden genau beobachten ob das
reicht ich bin aber auf jeden Fall auch
froh dass Tschechien jetzt
Grenzkontrollen zur Slowakei wieder
eingeführt hat und anschließend auch
Österreich Grenzkontrollen Richtung
Slowakei eingeführt hat wir müssen hier
eine strengere Kontrollen haben um den
illegalen Zuzug zu unterbinden und
gleichzeitig übrigens auch zu verhindern
dass beispielsweise verde hier russische
Leute eingeschleust werden da gab es
echte Flüchtlinge geben aber da muss man
bei Putin immer damit rechnen dass auch
andere Leute aus Russland zu uns
geschickt werden
noch leben die deutschen diese
Willkommenskultur nehmen die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge gerne auf
allerdings wir richten uns jetzt auch
wegen dieser massiv gestiegenen
Energiepreise und der erwarteten
gasknappheit auf einen harten Winter ein
die Wirtschaft steht von der Rezession
die Tafeln für die Bedürftigen die sind
schon am Rande der Möglichkeiten es
fehlen Wohnungen und und glauben Sie
dass das jetzt diese bisherige
Willkommenskultur den sozialen Frieden
in Deutschland doch gefährden könnte
das sehe ich schon als ein Problem an
das ist eine enorme Belastung für viele
Menschen deswegen war ich auch nicht so
begeistert davon dass die
Bundesregierung gleich entschieden hat
dass jeder ukrainische Flüchtling hier
bei uns sofort die volle deutsche
Sozialhilfe bekommt aber nächsten Januar
dann auch dieses Bürgergeld das ist ein
Schritt zu viel Aufnahme von
Flüchtlingen bei uns ja aber sie gleich
mit jedem deutschen
Sozialhilfeempfänger gleichzustellen da
ist meine sachens die Bundesregierung
einen Schritt zu weit gegangen und das
verstehen dann manche deutschen
Steuerzahler nicht mehr unbedingt aber
wie auch immer wir müssen jetzt schauen
dass wir noch mehr
Unterkunftsmöglichkeiten schaffen der
Bund hat angekündigt dazu jetzt auch
bundesliegenschaften noch mal zur
Verfügung zu stellen wir Warzen dringend
auf die klare Benennung wir werden dann
seltenste Länder alles dafür tun
zusammen mit den Kommunen noch mehr
Übernachtungsplätze zu schaffen aber
klar ist das wird relativ eng werden im
kommenden Winter und wir haben die von
Ihnen angesprochenen Energieprobleme und
die werden sich auch da bemerkbar machen
was glauben Sie wie sehr werden
rechtsextremistische Kräfte und auch die
AFD davon profitieren man muss ja nun
sagen die AFD ist ja auch nicht zuletzt
das Ergebnis einer Flüchtlingswelle von
2015 und wir haben ja jetzt auch bei der
letzten Landtagswahl schon gesehen die
AFD hat kräftig zugelegt
die AFD versucht hier ihr Süppchen zu
kochen das ist ganz offensichtlich das
verfängt bei dem ein oder anderen das
spüren wir auch ganz besonders in
Ostdeutschland ich sage aber auch klar
wenn wir sehen dass es führende Leute in
der AFD gibt die ganz offensichtlich
eigentlich für Putin mehr Verständnis
haben als für die Menschen in der
Ukraine dann muss man klar benennen was
das für Leute sind was Geistes Kind die
sind und deren Überlegungen können eben
nicht maßgeblich sein für uns in
Deutschland damit wir uns gegebenenfalls
auch hart auseinandersetzen und vor
allen Dingen die Kräfte in der AFD wir
die letztendlich auch mit unserer ganzen
Demokratie auf Kriegsfuß stehen den muss
man da natürlich auch klar
entgegentreten
wir haben tatsächlich auch beschämende
Bilder gesehen beschämende Bilder von
Demonstranten die eben gegen ukrainische
Flüchtlinge demonstrieren ihn genau
gegenüberstehen und ihnen sagen verpisst
euch geht weg das sind wirklich schlimme
Bilder was sagen die Ihnen wie es um den
sozialen Frieden momentan schon bei uns
steht
ich halte ein solches Verhalten für
wirklich völlig indiskutabel die Ukraine
ist von Russland von Putin angegriffen
worden wir erleben jetzt die
schrecklichen Bilder wieder Raketen
einschlagen dass da vor allen Dingen
viele Mütter mit Kindern geflohen sind
und jetzt im Moment bei uns leben bei
jeder Gelegenheit aber sagen sie möchten
so schnell wie möglich in ihre Heimat
zurückkehren da muss man denke ich
wirklich Verständnis dafür haben da ist
unsere Sympathie eindeutig bei diesen
Kriegsflüchtlingen und wenn sich da
einzelne Demonstranten derartig ja
wirklich unmenschlich verhalten da muss
man meine Sachen klar sagen pfui mit
solchen Leuten wollen wir wirklich
nichts zu tun haben und das ist auch
nicht die Mehrheitsmeinung der Deutschen
in unserem Land
sagt Innenminister Joachim Herrmann
vielen Dank dass Sie sich die Zeit für
uns genommen haben
[Musik]